Hank: Hello, and welcome to the very first
episode of "Dear Hank and John"
John: Or, as I like to think of it, "Dear
John and Hank".
We are John and Hank Green, and this podcast
is where we...
What, what do we do here Hank?
Hank: Uh...
This is the podcast where we answer your questions;
we are going to provide some dubious advice,
that we are not qualified to give; and also
give you all the week's news from Mars, the
planet, and also AFC Wimbledon, the 18th tier
English soccer club.
But first, John, how about a very short poem
for today.
John: Fourth tier for the record.
But, okay, we are going to start with a Langston
Hughes poem for today:
"Folks, I'm telling you,
birthing is hard
and dying is mean-
so get yourself
a little loving
in between."
John: That brings us nicely, Hank, to today's
first question, which is from Lindy, she writes:
"Dear John and Hank.
Hey, so there's this girl I really really
like, maybe even love, I don't know, this
is confusing.
I have felt like this for 6 years, the problem
is that I am also a girl, and she is straight.
How do I stop liking them as more than a friend?"
Hank: John, I just want to say, thank you
so much for starting us off with the hardest
question ever.
John: Yep.
Hank: How do you stop loving a person, John?
Umm...
Not my area of expertise.
My area of expertise is continuing to love
someone even when it's a bad idea.
Umm...
I thought this was more of a question for
Hank.
This seems like something that Hank would
be good at.
Hank: Uhh...
Right, well, just... just, if you say so.
Bury yourself in other things.
Just get really obsessed with bowling, and
just think, like, take all the energy that
you are focusing on this lovely person, and
focus it on getting...
being a really good bowler.
Or, uhh..., or you know, probably something
more useful that bowling would be a good idea.
John: Hank, do you know that that is literally
what I did my senior year of college?
Are you aware of that or was that-- did you
just coming up with bowling randomly?
Hank: No!
No, I looked over and I was like "I have to
find something" and I saw my bowling pin that
I won for getting-- I got a 199 that day and,
uh..., and so I won this bowling pin as a
trophy.
And that's what I saw so that's what I-- that's
what I hit.
John: I, uh, I was in a long term relationship
that ended and I was still very much in love
with this, uh, young woman that I was in a
relationship with.
And one of the things that I took up in the
wake of the relationship was bowling.
And I became an extremely passionate bowler.
I bowled every single day by myself at the
bowling alley in Mt.
Vernon, Ohio and I just loved it.
It was a wonderful release for me.
It was repetitious in a way that soothed my
brain.
I'm a huge fan of bowling and when you call
bowling useless, as I believe you just did,
it hurts me.
It hurts me deep down.
Hank: I just-- I mean, if you're gonna spend
500 hours getting over someone, which is at
least as long as it takes, you might wanna
focus on, like, maybe something like playing
guitar or accordion or maybe learning, uh...,
theoretical physics.
I don't know.
Bowling comes in handy.
I definitely go bowling and when I go bowling
and someone's really good at bowling I'm like
"Yeah!
You're really good at bowling!" and I think
that about them.
So, it's not like... completely useless.
Uh... it's as useless as being good at any
other sport.
Except that it's better because bowling is
something that everyone can enjoy together.
Uh, even if you're not bowling I feel like
you enjoy bowling just as much as people who
are.
If I'm going to the bowling alley and, like,
my shoulder hurts, which it does sometimes,
and I don't bowl.
I still have a good time!
Because bowling is really more about sitting
around.
John: So Lindy, I think, um..., I think we've
arrived upon a solution for you.
Um..., it's not easy, uh..., to change your
feelings about someone or to wait out your
feelings about someone or to sublimate them,
but the key is bowling!
Your welcome!
God, we're so good at advice!
Hank: Yeah!
John: Um, this one is from Lucas.
"Dear John and Hank, What is your favorite
thing to look at in the night sky?"
Hank: Well.
Yeah, I, um, there's a lot to choose from,
I think I'm gonna cop, like, go with a cop
out answer here and say the Milky Way, 'cause
if you can see it, which you can't always
in a lot of the country, but here in Montana,
we often can.
If you can see the Milky Way, it is the most
amazing, awe-inspiring, like, tear-inducing,
put-you-in-your-placing thing that you can
see.
Um, it's a really beautiful thing, and it's
a really beautiful thing that you can see,
it's a really beautiful thing and it's a really
beautiful experience to like, really look
at the galaxy and be like, there it is, and
I can only see it in that direction, which
means that we're sittin' out here on the edge
of it, and it's a big beautiful thing.
I think that that is by far the most sort
of beautiful thing you can see in the night
sky with your naked eye.
Of course, it's--I'm saying it's a cop out
because it is not a thing, it is many billion
things.
John: For me, it's the middle star in Orion's
belt.
What I like to think of as Orion's belt buckle.
That's my favorite thing to look at.
That was a very fancy answer, Hank, but I
like Orion's belt buckle.
It just, it reminds me of where I am in the
world.
Hank: That star is called Alnilam, and it
is a, a super g--a blue supergiant, which
is a big, a big star, and it is only 1,340
light years away, John, and yes, I did just
look that up on Wikipedia.
John: Quick question about blue giant stars.
Are they about to die?
Like, what is, what are the chances that I'm
going to stop enjoying Orion's belt buckle
because it turns into a supernova?
Hank: I think that you're safe for your lifetime.
John: Okay.
What about like, young people watching this
podcast, or listening to it?
Hank: I don't know offhand about the average
age of a blue supergiant, but in general,
the lifetime of a human is not consequential.
John: Ah, the lifetime of a human is not consequential.
You really, one really does come here to get
the good news.
John: Do you have a question?
Hank: I do.
"Dear Hank and John", this is from Claire.
"I graduated from high school three days ago,
and next year I'm going to a very prestigious
university."
Well, thanks for letting us know how prestigious
your university is, Claire.
"This is good," she says.
"I'm very happy that the black magic of college
admissions somehow spun in my favor, but this
school, it is expensive and has lots of amazing
resources across the board from engineering
to the arts and back.
I just want to milk my 32 courses for all
their worth, so I'm curious, what do you guys
think, what should I study to be the biggest
help to the world?
Please assume for the sake of argument that
I'm equally good at all academic disciplines,
which, while untrue, is my rhetorical stance."
John: That is a fascinating question.
I think Claire is in for big things, no matter
what she does, given the quality of her question
asking.
I'm interested to know what you think, Hank.
Hank: I'm super into the idea of having a
really diverse base of knowledge.
So if you got 32 classes, you know, you're
gonna have to focus on something because they
require you to major in things in college,
but do your best to have a broad, a broad
experience and like, as long as everything
that you're taking is in some way challenging,
so it like--that's what you want, you want
to be challenged, and you want to not hate
your life, so that's what you should try and
do with college.
John: And everything else.
Hank: Yeah, and your entire life.
John: I am a huge Roger Ebert fan, Hank, the
great film critic who was also something of
a public intellectual, like, he wasn't, he
studied film and, you know, wrote film reviews
for most of his career, but he also studied
a lot of other things, and had a lot of other
fields that he found interesting, and I thought
that idea, like, I feel like that idea of
the public intellectual has sort of fallen
away in this era of specialization, and there
are great things about specialization, but
I completely agree with you, um, when you
specialize in unexpected ways, when you have--when
you can make unexpected connections between
worlds that people think of as separate, that
really makes you stand out, so I think that's
the, that's the best of what higher education
has to offer now, and I totally agree that
Claire should embrace that.
John: Hank, we have another question, this
is from Ava, "Dear John and Hank, will you
come to our wedding in British Columbia on
July 11th?"
Ava, let me just answer before Hank does,
because Hank lives very close to British Columbia,
not at all inconvenient to him, he has no
children, I can't see a reason why he wouldn't
go, unless he's just a jerk, but I can't go,
because I will be supporting the movie adaptation
of my book Paper Towns, and I have previous
commitments.
I'm so sorry, Ava, but I'm sure that Hank
is gonna say yes.
Hank: I am doing colonoscopy prep doing that
day, so.
John: Wow, that's actually a fantastic excuse.
Hank: Yeah, I gotta, gotta drink a bunch of
awful snot that makes me turn into a poop
volcano.
John: That is one high-quality excuse for
not attending a wedding.
Congratulations.
And congratulations to you as well, Ava.
We will send a gift.
Hank: Will we?
I think this is the gift.
John: No, no, no, we'll send a gift, we'll
get them something.
She didn't even tell us where she was registered.
I don't feel like I got a formal invitation,
y'know?
She just e-mailed hankandjohn@gmail.com, I
didn't--there was nothing letter-pressed,
I don't like to criticize peoples' wedding
invitation strategies, because certainly I
think the wedding industry is a bit bloated,
but I mean, y'know, you could have sent something
in the mail, Ava.
Hank: Okay, here's another question, this
one is from Sam.
Sam says, "Dear Hank and John, do you guys
have faith that humans will eventually colonize
the galaxy?"
John: NO.
I can answer that in one word.
No.
I do not think that we will ever colonize
the galaxy.
The galaxy is very--all the other stars are
so far away.
Hank: I--I was really interested to hear your
answer to this question, John, because I didn't--I
honestly didn't know which way you were gonna
go.
I think we already have.
John: What?
Hank: Just a very small part of the galaxy,
we have colonized.
John: Do you mean Earth and Mars?
Hank: No, I mean Earth.
Just Earth.
John: We have done an amazing job of colonizing
Earth, I mean, we--
Hank: We have colonized the crap out Earth.
John--own this planet.
Hank: Yeah.
John: There is hardly a square inch of this
planet that humans have not either lived in
or peed in.
Hank: We definitely--humans have peed on every
single part of the planet, definitely.
John: Yeah, no, there is--you can't find us
everywhere on this planet, but you can find
our waste everywhere.
Hank: Yeah.
I would actually be interested to see a map
of where humans haven't peed.
I bet there's some places, I mean, there's
certainly some places in Antarctica and maybe
the Sahara were humans haven't peed.
John: Oh, there's large swaths of the ocean
where we haven't peed, but I would argue that
our pee is filtered out into the rest of the
ocean, I mean, if you pee--
Hank: Oh, certainly, once you pee in the ocean,
once, you've peed in the entire ocean.
John: Yeah, so if you've peed in the Atlantic,
you've, by the law of transitive ocean peeing,
you've also peed in the Pacific, because it's
all connected.
It's really just one body of water that we
have named various oceans, so you've peed
in the one human--the one Earth ocean.
Hank: That's true.
That's true.
John: Really, if you've peed in any body of
water that's con--if you've peed in a river,
you've peed in the ocean.
This is getting pretty meta, Hank--
Hank: Yeah.
John:--but when I peed in the White River,
I technically peed in the, in the Indian Ocean.
Hank: Here's a question for you.
If you've peed in the White River, did you
pee into a cloud?
Because eventually that water that was in
your pee, is--some of it's gonna end up in
clouds.
John: Not just in clouds, Hank, but also it's
gonna end up in rain that's gonna end up falling
on Antarctica.
Does it rain there?
I don't know.
Hank: It doesn't--(laughs) The question is,
did you pee on your own head?
John: I'm more concerned with whether I have
successfully peed on all seven continents,
and you refuse to answer that, because you
also don't know if it rains in Antarctica.
Sam, if we can zoom out of your question a
little bit, if you're referring to us colonizing
non-solar system things, there's no way in
10,000 years we could even get to another
planetary--it just--it's not possible, unfortunately.
It would be awesome.
I love Star Trek, it's just not possible.
Hank: My serious answer to Sam is that in
10,000 years, no.
In 100,000 years, I don't know.
In a million years, if humans are still around,
we may have found ways to inhabit other star
systems, it is--it would be a very slow process,
unless some kind of faster than light travel
was developed in which case, more power to
us, but I feel like if faster than light travel
was possible, we would have seen aliens by
now.
John: Let me just back up and respond to a
different part of that, which is that your
proposal that human beings might exist in
a million years, which is ludicrous.
Of all the things, of all the ridiculous things
involved in colonizing other stars in the
galaxy, the part where we still have humans
in a million years is the most ridiculous.
Hank: Are you saying million or billion?
John: Million with an M.
Hank: I completely disagree with you, it is
entirely possible that there will still be
humans in a million years.
John: I mean--
Hank: Why would you, why would you--
John: I will bet you a hundred dollars right
now that there will be no humans in a million
years.
Hank: I take the bet!
John: Alright.
I can't lose.
I'm not gonna lose.
There is--we, we are lucky if we have 5,000
years.
Our species is insane.
It's insa--the greed, the consumption, the,
the, the mutually assured self-destruction,
oh, we are in the second half of being people,
for sure.
For sure!
Hank: I--well, even if we are in the second
half of being people...
John: I know, we might, we might have up to
100,000 years, at the very, the very best
that could happen, 100,000 years.
Hank: There's a--there's a lot, there's a
lot of potential future, but there are also
many, many species that have been around for
longer than a million years.
They may not be any--in any way like us--
John: Right, yeah.
Hank: --but--
John: I don't know, that's like saying 'this
rock is really old, so I bet I'll live forever,
too.'
Hank: Alright.
I--I think I--I think that the future is unknowable.
John: Why don't--you--why don't you ask the
next question?
Hank: "Dear Hank and John, What if a guy says
I'm too smart for him?"
John: This question came from Rebecca.
Here is my advice, Rebecca.
So I want you to go to a mirror, find a mirror
somewhere, and then I always find it helpful
to practice my faces in the mirror, Hank,
do you know what I mean?
Like, I just try to practice--
Hank: Yeah.
John: --so that I know what people are seeing
when I make a face.
That if I'm trying to communicate an emotion
with my face, I want them to--I wanna know
what they're seeing, you know, like what my
happy face looks like, et cetera?
Hank: Mhmm.
John: So, Rebecca, I want you to go to a mirror,
and I want you to put on a face of horror.
Like, uh, like just horrified.
And then I want you to like, slightly transfigure
that face to add in intense disgust.
And then I want you to hold on to that face,
figure out what it looks like, and the next
time someone tells you that, that, that you
are too smart for them, I want you to make
that face, and then I want you to say, "No,
no, no, no, no, no, you are no longer under
consideration."
And then back away and move on with your life.
Take up bowling.
Hank: Take up bowling.
I--yeah, I think the answer to that question
or the response to 'you're too smart for me'
is, 'yeah, I think you're right.'
John: (Laughs) "I'm glad that we're on the
same page about this.
I didn't know that I was too smart for you
until just now but thank you for confirming
it."
Hank: (Laughs) "Thanks, thanks for letting
me know."
John: Hank, we only have, uh, we only have
time in this first podcast for one more question.
Um, it comes from Egide, I hope I said your
name right Egide.
"Dear John and Hank.
I really like what you guys do on YouTube.
I was just wondering, who does your parents
think is the better son?"
Hank: Oh wow.
Um...
John: That's easy.
Hank: Is it?
John: Let's just, let's just answer on three,
OK?
We'll answer together, that way your opinion
won't shape mine or anything.
We'll just answer on three.
Hank: OK.
John: 1, 2, 3.
Hank.
Hank: Dave.
John: No!
You are cheating!
That's not, that's total cheating!
I stayed true to the rules of the game that
I invented and you cheated.
Typical!
Hank: I just think that our parents really
like Dave.
John: They do like Dave.
John: Alright Hank, it's time for the news
from Mars, which is a small planet on the
edge of the Milky Way galaxy, and the news
from AFC Wimbledon, which is the most important
soccer team in the history of the world.
Hank: That's what we do at the end of the
podcast, John.
Why do we do it?
John: Uh, well, because you love Mars, I love
AFC Wimbledon, and people love to learn about
Mars and AFC Wimbledon.
Hank: This week NASA is testing the Low-Density
Supersonic Deceleration System which is also
called the LDSD.
John: Because God forbid NASA makes something
without having an appropriate acronym.
Hank: Well, you gotta write, it's a lot of
words.
You've gotta have a fast way to write it down.
So the LDSD's job is to deliver larger payloads
than we can currently deliver to the surface
off Mars.
There's this problem that you have when you're
travelling interplanetarily that you are going
very fast when you arrive at your destination
and you have to slow down and it is difficult
to slow down.
So one of the things that they do to slow
down is they just hit the atmosphere and let
the atmosphere slow the craft down and then
eventually open parachutes and the parachutes
will further slow the craft down and then,
like at the last moment, you fire some rockets
maybe.
The problem that Mars has is that there isn't
a ton of air in the atmosphere so parachutes
won't open higher in the atmosphere so you
can't slow down as fast as you would like
especially if your craft is super heavy.
The job of the LDSD is to, uh, it basically
inflates to make the craft bigger.
It's like a bunch of balloons, like airbags
on the side of the craft that catch the atmosphere,
increase its surface area so it can slow down
faster before deploying the parachutes.
And that increases the payloads we can deliver
to Mars from, like, one and a half tons to
up to three tons which is twice as much.
Very exciting.
John: So I just want to confirm, Hank, that
the most interesting thing that happened on
Mars this week happened on Earth.
Hank: Well that is almost always gonna be
the case.
It's gonna be more the news in Mars and regarding
Mars.
John: When Hank and I initially came up with
the idea for this podcast we were like "Oh,
and we'll do the news from Mars and AFC Wimbledon"
and then Hank literally said to me "But is
there news from AFC Wimbledon every week?"
And I'm like "Is there news from Mars every
week?"
Hank: I, like, I just don't understand your
proposition that somehow AFC Wimbledon and
Mars are on the same plane of interest.
John: No, listen.
To be clear, I am not proposing that AFC Wimbledon
and Mars are on the same plane.
I am proposing that AFC Wimbledon is in fact
far more important than Mars.
Hank: Yeah, I have a really hard time with
this.
I mean, if you look at the amount of, like,
attention and money spent on one of those
two things, much more attention and money
is spent on Mars.
Like, this is a true fact.
John: Mars is a cold, dead rock.
Much like any of the gajillions of cold dead
rocks scattered throughout the universe.
Not only that, but you can find, you can find
cold dead rocks right here on earth.
You don't have to go to space to get one.
However, you do have to go to South London
to get AFC Wimbledon.
So, can we get, instead of arguing about whether
Mars is more interesting than AFC Wimbledon,
which is a settled question because AFC Wimbledon
is more interesting, can we get to the news
from AFC Wimbledon this week?
Hank: That is acceptable.
John: Okay Hank, so AFC Wimbledon, the fourth-tier
English soccer team that plays in South London,
has three on-the-uniform spots for sponsorship.
Right.
So there's the front of the shirt, there's
the back of the shirt, and then there's the
back of the shorts.
You know what I'm talking about?
Hank: Yeah yeah yeah.
John: So you've got like a corporate name
on each of those places.
So Hank, can you guess what savvy marketing-oriented
corporation will be advertising itself on
the lower left buttock of next season's AFC
Wimbledon uniform?
Can you guess?
Hank: Is it, uh, DFTBA Records?
John: It's us!
That's right!
It is us.
Their shorts will again say DFTBA Nerdfighteria
right there in that wonderful liminal space
between left thigh and left buttock.
I am so excited to be able to announce this
week that the 2015-2016 AFC Wimbledon uniform
will again remind its players and opponents
who are running behind its players not to
forget to be awesome.
I'm very excited.
The season is over for AFC Wimbledon, but
of course the news AFC Wimbledon-wise continues
year-round so we'll have plenty to discuss
in this exciting off-season, as AFC Wimbledon
attempts to strengthen their squad to really
push up, to maybe next year make it to the
third tier of English football.
Hank: And as I'm going to attempt to feign
interest in your weird interests, how are
they doing these days, John?
John: Well Hank, as I just told you, the season
has ended, so they aren't currently playing.
Hank: But how did they do?
How did they do?
Did they do okay?
John: What do you mean "how did they do?"
Do you never look to see how their doing?
What do you do all day?
Like I don't understand what you look at on
the internet if you aren't looking at least
occasionally at soccer standings in fourth-tier
English football.
Like, what is it on the internet that you
look at instead?
Hank: ...Mars stuff.
John: Aaalright.
They finished 15th in League 2 this year,
so-called because it's the fourth league of
English football.
It goes the Premier League, then the Championship,
then League 1, then League 2, and then you
aren't in the league anymore, you're not a
professional team.
So you want to stay at least in League 2.
So they finished 15th in League 2, comfortably
mid-table, but next season we'll be looking
to really push toward the top half of that
table and maybe even into the top few spots
that get up to League 1.
Hank: This sounds complicated, John.
John: Not as complicated as building a thing
to go on Mars the size of a minivan.
Hank: Yeah, and also not as cool.
(John laughs)
John: So what did we learn today, Hank?
Hank: We learned that love is hard, and that
we're not going to go to Ava's wedding.
John: Yup.
We also learned that we're probably not going
to go to colonize other stars in the galaxy,
and we learned that while love is hard, and
it's hard to move on from love, there is always
what Emily Dickinson so beautifully called
"hope, that thing with feathers."
Which today comes in the form of bowling.
Hank: And the human lifespan is insignificant.
John: Thanks for listening to Dear Hank & John,
or as I like to think of it, Dear John & Hank.
You can email us your questions and problems
and anything else that you want to email us,
at hankandjohn@gmail.com.
Obviously Hank registered that email address.
But thanks again for listening and as we say
in our hometown of nerdfighteria...
Hank: Don't forget to be awesome.